hello I'm the Nostalgia guy remember it
so you don't have to let's talk a little
history in 1862 Anna Leonowens what's
given the opportunity to teach the many
wives and children of long cooked the
King of Siam she accepted and later
wrote a series of memoirs about her
experience called the English governess
at the Siamese Court the memoirs were
controversial to say the least many
saying she exaggerated or downright
fabricated her influence on the king and
that she reduced a man who was a
Buddhist monk for 27 years into a cruel
extreme even violent monarch years later
Margaret Landon wrote of fictionalize or
even more fictionalized version called a
nun the King of Siam again reinforcing
Anna's the revolutionary emblem code as
the harsh eccentric ruler Thailand
finally said I we've added up to here
with your bullshit we're going to write
our own version for English readers
which will later become Hmong got the
King of Siam and our writings will be
placed in the Library of Congress for
all you readers to see the truth
maybe then America will know the true
history of our beloved King Dermot
Rodgers and Hammerstein's the King and I
came out glorifying Landon's book and
making her story more popular than it's
ever been
so the controversy about telling only
one side of the story continued from
here on but then another adaptation came
out this time in animated form under the
same name
the king of
getting to know about animated by Warner
Brothers and released in 1999 this movie
surely would offer a new outlook on
history and myth not unlike something
like The Prince of Egypt did taking a
relatively famous tale but updating it
with modern dramatic storytelling while
still coming from a different but
respectful point of view perhaps
Thailand's dignified look on their
beloved King will finally come to light
so tell me how does this look back on
history begin this is big enough did I
see that right I mean dad really see
that right a dragon we're starting off
the King and I with a fucking dragon
what been a bumpy it's produced this
cinematic idiocy that whole see how it
makes sense rankin/bass the same
animation team who made the stop-motion
specials that put more emphasis on the
start than the motion and produced a
whole slew of what I like to call
awkward nation the cartoons that were
never good but you were just so
fascinated by how strangely they moved
that you had no choice but to keep
watching this film doesn't even have
that distinction
it has good animation to an extent it's
good Warner Brothers animation trying to
be good Disney animation resulting in
Bad Warner Brothers animation but
honestly I'm probably getting ahead of
myself let's look at how this film
begins the governess is being
transported to Thailand during a nasty
storm
clearly she's already doing a bang-up
duty of her job as her son is climbing
the edge of the foe for his pet monkey
I'm sure she'll do great looking after
those kids Mia Mia on the wall who's the
loses adaptation of all I lose this
English schoolteacher to help me d
throne the king actually this is the
Prime Minister Khurana home
in the original film he's a stone-faced
traditionalists who believes in the old
ways trying to help the king run a good
government but still keep true to his
traditions this one comes pretty close
here he's an evil wizard who wants to
dethrone the king by using his magic
powers to take over all this I am tall
and the Japanese didn't fire at
hospitals why what upon hearing that the
schoolteacher is arriving he comes up
with a plan so evil that makes rats jump
out of his shadow you heard right rats
jump out of his shadow like one of the
missing Grinch lyrics you are mean one
crawl home you have watts in your shadow
you dance as horribly as are drunk Ricky
Ricardo crawl
thank God the person this is based on is
dead and he has no estate to sue you
because if they could no I don't get it
you're right but you gonna explain to me
now huh he also has a psychic plays like
Darrell Hammond named master little why
does he have a sidekick in this version
because everybody has a funny little
sidekick in this movie in fact we can
probably just go ahead and start the
funny little sidekick count the monkey
most racist interpretation since
Breakfast at Tiffany's the dragon okay
we won't count him but yeah I'd say
let's address the white elephant in the
room but we don't need to it's one of
the funny little sidekicks coming up and
speaking of awkwardness that needs to be
addressed
Paula Hong does indeed send a dragon to
attack them which doesn't make sense
seeing how a second ago he said he
wanted her for his plans so why is he
trying to scare her away but thankfully
Ana has a foolproof way to fight him off
whistling now in the original she tells
her son that she whistles because she's
afraid to meet the king and sometimes
her nerds get to her here it's a
frigging dragon kill it with fire Spears
rocks but not a musical number you
should be singing about the wonders of a
semi-automatic and twirling yes
whirling will confuse the savage beast
where dinosaurs always based their sight
on movement dragons apparently based
their sight on not movement so I guess
they eat a lot of rocks but you want to
know the really bizarre thing about all
of this and trust me it's not easy
sentence to say considering what we put
on screen no no the really bizarre thing
about all of this is it works yeah
the monster disappears
I guess whistling and twirling and now
permanent additions to the naval defense
so they make it to Epcot Island where
Anna is finally introduced to the king
his high-fiving Panther his penises
resume their comely sidekicks and of
course his possible multiple wives yeah
and the original there's no mistake
they're definitely his wives but here
they never clarify whether these are
wives or servants I guess either way it
doesn't matter as we can just assume
he's putting his dick in them but still
a little clarity would be nice while one
of the newer servants is shown around
the palace she comes across her own
cuddly playmate I shall call you duster
and the King's eldest son Luca object
like rug given to King oh good I'm glad
you know that you see usually I have to
talk to girls and treat them like
individuals but you seem to be ahead of
the game but I Jafar it turns out seems
to have a new sinister plan if the boy
gets hurt the king will be blamed we're
going to mess him up so first it was
make the King look like a barbarian to
Anna then it was scary Anna away with a
dragon now it's try to kill Anna's son
you're like a one-man political debate
you can't stay agreed on anything you
like focus
you'll need somehow you have to be
bright to face my nose so while most of
the audience refills their popcorn
because clearly they know the next two
minutes is nothing but this shang tsung
decides to write a letter to the british
fleet to make it look like the king is
treating anna horribly oh sure it
follows twelve trees died to give you
that scene folks was worth it where to
Siam to dethrone a barbaric king
we got a random letter let's destroy a
nation but of course Anna is fine but
apparently having trouble teaching her
pupils Siam is not so small oh but look
England's even smaller but royal palace
is centre of whole universe you know the
irony is that this misunderstanding of
history from delusional people at the
top who think they're always right can
just as easily be translated into
American film animation I mean really
think about it
so let us begin with the history of
Thailand culture Thailand culture come
from big dragon big dragon decide who
they been who died and those let create
a talent all right why don't we come
back to Thailand history let's instead
look at the pork industry
ah I love in history John Smith's it's
my fault good Indian princess
they have romance and talk to singing
three alright welcome back to that too
what do you know about Russian history
that's beautiful yes
what's an evil wizard with a fucking bat
who cast spells on another pretty
princess pretty princesses make up most
of world history
you know let's get a break and I'll read
to you from some English literature like
The Little Mermaid who sacrifices her
life Antonia it's a very ancient saying
but a true and honest thought so this
leads to the musicals most famous song
and coincidentally the most annoying
thank God once again the focus isn't on
the interaction of the characters of
their relationships but rather an excuse
to have the comic relief dis practice
with their rush to dumbass humor this
serves a specially humor is here as the
song is entitled getting to know you and
yet by paying more attention to the
Dragons animals and comedic antics I
don't know anything about these people
it's like everything that should be in
the foreground is in the background and
everything that should be in the
background is in the foreground I mean
it's like people focusing more on the
color of the wall than the person
actually in front of it really guys
really
okay well let's go to commercial I try
to fix this clearly this is really
important like the show can't go on with
this abomination behind me I mean here I
thought the most important thing about
them - Strausser Critic what that is
sounds you're pretty but no it's the
color of the fucking wall that's the
glue that held everything together so
I'll be right back we're going to marry
when the King and I the musical your
parents tried to show you after forcing
you to watch sound of the music comes
the 57th anniversary recording of the
classic Rodgers and Hammerstein's music
featuring Hollywood's latest
groundbreaking musical discovery Russell
Crowe behold the musical sensation from
lay misery and whatever the hell bad
he's in delighting the world with his
angelic instrument Russell what seems to
be a problem okay whistle Pole that's
okay we'll just step over in post
nobody dubs over me Pole we'll just we
brought the music so I can sing it
easier I think that might be a little
disrespectful to the original material
nonsense perhaps you didn't hear my
incredible performance in Les Miserables
I did that's why I was a little
concerned all the critics praised me
they said they'd never heard anything
like it if Anne Hathaway didn't get the
academy award I may be one of that des
Supporting Actress now we brought the
music before I punch you violently will
do also featuring the world renowned
artist from the 90s Chuck here
cut recording Russell you doing a great
job um but do you think you could try it
this time with a little more motion Roy
here's what I was thinking I was
thinking maybe I could squid my eyes and
frown how about that or maybe you could
try something else
I don't think so order now and you can
get other Hollywood sensation Gerard
Butler singing your child to sleep with
nursery rhymes the King and I sung by
Russell Crowe because by God
somebody has to humor him
and boom there you go trying to
recapture the glory days it's kind of
you want to step it up a bit try
something new okay Oh welcome somewhere
I can hide behind all his high-tech
effects so he could disguise the fact he
doesn't try anymore
oh now he's trying too hard could he be
any more obvious hmm I'm allergic to
popcorn he's so insensitive never
thinking of us you know what I miss the
days when he had good bird
I'd be so retro if he went back to the
white wall so in keeping with the theme
of put his little attention on our main
characters as possible the King sings
about the changes of the world and where
he belongs in it but also while Giant
Killer statues come to destroy him
oh thank god I almost thought the song
served a purpose and my father was a
teen he was a king who knew exactly what
he knew
but it's okay because the comedic
Panther discovers quickly what can stop
them all roar OH
roar what is it this Wizards powers seem
to be defeated by the lamest things
hahaha now I will send in the powerful
Godzilla Oh somebody eat a Mentos well
this time I'm sending in the horrifying
tiniest creatures that God in His wisdom
could not deserve those diseases
I'm a bad wizard you're an idiot
so the king gets a letter saying the
British are coming to kick him out
because they think he's a barbarian they
call me barbarian Oh certain parties who
wish to steal my country do you believe
it not it's a lie a false lie doesn't
that technically make it truth so the
British arrived and everything seems to
be going well until he discovers that
his son has given away a secret piece of
jewelry to one of the servants you gave
away father may we discuss this
privately
what okay you're Daffy Duck
impersonation is really gonna need some
work this servant oh and Prince
forbidden do as custom demand down down
no this might be really inappropriate
but seeing how this is a rankin/bass
production during the scene could we
play this oh if you know the story you
know he can't bring himself to do it but
he does order her to be sent back to
Burma but the prince in her escape and
try to run away go to the ancient place
of the elephant spring back their bodies
after is going to be an accident
you know guy you keep coming up with
these complicated ways to seize power
have you ever thought about just going
up to a really powerful nation and being
like doh
Huygens I can make dragons give me all
your shit so the servant falls into the
pepsi-cola River but luckily the King
has his air balloon to try and save the
day I must say so I can give her a
proper whipping crawl a home sits the
balloon on fire while the king is still
inside
thanks for happy all things considered I
couldn't be better I'm a thing yeah I
can't explain this um though I didn't so
the family goes to look over the damaged
well the Panther was given his prognosis
he's definitely dead folks I will say
when his time to cry so he apparently
lives in this version and Anna even
seems to stay behind you could make the
argument that this is totally spitting
in the face of history but the other
versions seem to do that already this is
more a scrotum shaving of history
painful insulting and not nearly short
enough to describe this movie overall
whether you like the original musical or
not I think everyone can agree this is
beyond a serious downgrade the
child-friendly additions are so painful
and so out of place but I keep expecting
to see the Saturday TV funhouse logo pop
up from SNL I've learned more about
Thailand by eating at a Thai restaurant
it cares nothing for its main characters
and instead wants to focus on its
comedic side characters which even then
aren't really that developed either and
we get down to it it doesn't even make
any sense
why make a kid-friendly version of
something like this anyway did they
really think there was gonna be a big
enough crowd for it all I can say is you
won't see me trying to cash in on some
dying musical fad I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remembered so you don't have to
it's never funny to begin with stop it